chuckle got a question he actually wrote
that yeah he did
yep he's fully in-game question oh how
would you do with a team member who
tries to take all the responsibility but
cannot do as good a job as others I
don't know if it's sincere helpfulness
or a desire of power but these are for
power there's a little twist on that one
yeah a little twist that puts them all
on that question right there and so you
got a guy that's one trying to take all
this responsibility for everything and
not really as good as he should be to me
in that position but trying to take
responsibility and yet the person that's
got the question he doesn't know if it's
sincere trying to just help out the team
or a desire for power so is it
helpfulness or is it their quest for
power where they come in from how do we
figure that out well for one thing if
someone is truly trying to help the team
they will have an open mind to support
and suggestion and help from other
people they'll be open to that because
they're just trying to do the best for
the team if they're trying to take or
maintain power which as we know is
driven by ego they don't want help and
they don't want suggestions from people
either they're just gonna do it my way I
got this no it's mine so that's the
difference so there's gonna be two
different ways that I'm gonna handle
this situation so for a person that's
actually trying to help and trying to do
a good job I'm gonna bolster them up I
love it the fact that they have some
shortfalls that's okay you know I'm
gonna do I'm gonna give them some
support I'm gonna put some people on
their team that can help cover some of
those shortfalls I'm gonna try and set
them up to win and learn and be educated
while they are winning and if they're
humble which I'm assuming that they are
because they have this attitude that
they're trying to help out everyone then
did while I'm doing this whole process
of course I'm coaching them and a mentor
them and giving them suggestions and I'm
turning to someone that can do a good
job in that situation so that's pretty
you got someone that wants to take
ownership responsibility and they're
doing it for the right reasons boom
let's help them out let's support them
let's get them training let's get them
knowledge and let's get them up to speed
we got a upcoming leader I dig it if
it's an ego driven person and they are
maneuvering for the power well then what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna let them get
humbled by the experience because
remember it stated that they're not as
good as they could be at this job
they're not particularly good at what
they're trying to take control over so
that's fine I'm gonna let him get
humbled by it now I'm going to assess
the risk so I'm gonna make sure that no
one's gonna get hurt or no one's gonna
get killed or we're not gonna fail a
mission or in the business world make
sure they're not gonna lose millions of
dollars we're not going to suffer comes
some kind of a strategic setback but I'm
gonna let them fail a little bit and let
them see that they're not as good as
they think they are I'm gonna let them
learn about humility right I'm gonna let
them learn about humility now if they
learn if they are humbled by that and
they realize that they're not as good as
they realize that they're not ready to
control everything and they realize that
they need help if they learn from it and
they don't just cast blame then they'll
become a much better leader mmm you will
actually help them by letting them get
humbled if they just get done and they
just cast blame then we see them fail
and now we have legitimate reason to say
look I can't put you in charge you just
failed I can't allow this to happen
again so that's how I would basically
handle that situation now of course
there's all different kind of gradations
of those realities and the answer will
be somewhat scaled as well right so
that's what you do you scale the answer
maybe you get it's personal a little bit
of help but you know let them stumble a
little bit you know maybe you're not
gonna get many help at all you don't
fall flat on their face maybe you're
gonna bolster them up a lot but you're
still gonna talk to them and say hey
listen you need to step back and get
more in the weeds on some of the lower
level stuff because you're not ready to
manage this yet you know so it's cool
but that's my basic overall concept of
where I would be going with that
do you find that like even with the
expression extreme ownership or in this
case matrix all the responsibility do
you find that not people get confused
but you know yeah like people who will
kind of get confused you know how you
say okay take responsibility because it
seems like anyway from what I told think
I totally understand with extreme
ownership is for the mistakes in the
solution yes right that is a dream
ownership so and then but then it from
what I heard like sometimes when people
ask questions it'll kind of this one's
kind of ambiguous but sometimes people
will ask it ask a question or make a
statement comment whatever in terms of
take responsibility or take ownership of
like not of the problems or the
solutions but but like before them is
like this is my yeah this is yeah you
can overstep you can be you can use too
much extreme ownership you can say hey
this is my echo this is my mission I'll
tell you how to do it yeah you know you
know input from you not to call me yeah
yeah and by the way I'm taking all the
credit to when we get back which is
actually equally wrong right I should do
is say hey I will echo I'm in charge of
this but hey man I want you to come up
with a good plan I think you've got a
great insight I think you know the
terrain better than me can you come up
with a good plan and then we get
backwards if it's a successful mission
I'm like hey guys everyone look what
echo did and I tell the commanding
officer echo ran this great operation I
think he's ready to step up in
leadership he really did a superb job if
it fails what am i doing pointing the
finger back oh no I'm coming back and
saying hey boss here's a mission failure
these are mistakes I made here's what I
did wrong here's what I'm gonna fix next
time that's real simple so would you say
in a nutshell extreme ownership applies
to the problems and the solutions to
those problems and that's all know it
applies to everything it applies to
everything because even when I say hey I
want you come up with a plan for this
you come back and brief me with a plan
yeah I still take ownership of the plan
it's your
plan but I go through it I say okay this
looks like a good move hey echo I'm
looking at this right here I don't know
if this is the best way to execute this
here's the issue so I'm not taking
ownership of it that I'm just pulling it
away from you but I'm definitely gonna
make sure we win I that's the thing that
drives me crazy sometimes with leaders
is they don't realize it but they're
making excuses because they'll say oh
you know I let I let me i'm
decentralized command so i I can't
control everything
no actually you are responsible for
everything and if I got three teams out
there and you're one of the team leaders
and I come to you and say hey echo
here's the plan I want you to execute I
still have to look at the plan I still
have to make sure that I agree with what
you doin have to make sure you're not
doing something that doesn't make sense
well yes I do have ownership of the plan
yeah absolutely like it's your family
member or something you know that plan
is like it's oh I love it like a son
yeah the plan is the plan you came up
with a plan you created it it's my
grandkid yeah yeah right
so you're it's yours but I'm still gonna
take responsibility and ownership about
where people it's when your ego starts
flaring up and I start saying no that's
my plan and we're my way that's where we
have issues yeah but yeah the ownership
doesn't stop and it just doesn't stop
when you're in a leadership position it
doesn't stop you own everything up and
down the chain of command it's hard to
do it's hard on your ego for sure yeah
because it kind of seems in a way
counter to I guess if you understand
though all the little subtle dynamics of
it cuz you know how like if the plan
fails boom that's one extreme ownership
is really gonna show it but if it's a
super successful flawless plan it
doesn't it's more covert because it's
more internal because you got to give
the credit for everyone else everyone
will sit there and go oh Jacko's you
know he's he's given the credit to echo
for the operation he won't show up as
extreme ownership for sure it'll be
harder to see yeah and if people will
say dang people know that I was in
charge right then it won me over all ago
so I'm still gonna get some credit right
it's more covert but but it's way more
covert and it's matter yeah better
that's that's the hard life that's
what's so hard for people to realize
they want so bad to raise their hand and
say yes it was me it was my mom
operation but it doesn't help you it
doesn't help you it feels good for like
a half a second and then you realize you
just deflated yourself is that kind of
like when you make a donation to charity
but you want like everyone to know that
you did it it's kind of like that yeah I
guess it's similar to that similar
concept right like in a weird kind of
profound way I guess we'll just move on
the next question how about just the
profoundness of your last day on a
certain level it's the same thing
because you know you did something good
you know or you are something good or
whatever but it's like saying I'm I'm
the most humble guy in the world you
know I'm just down to here's the other
thing about this when I give you the
credit for success yeah not only do I
win covertly in that you look at me and
go man he gave me a couple Corrections
that weren't critical this operation
he's not even saying anything so you
have even more respect for me which
means you're gonna work harder for me in
the future you're gonna do even more and
we're gonna look even better so I am
gonna ultimately win yeah because my
team is gonna be kicking so much ass all
over the globe and people are saying wow
you know this these guys are just
winning everywhere they go well and and
and so it's very very positive whereas
if I took that credit from you on that
first operation and I took it from you
how are you working on that next one not
as hard not as hard you know maybe
you're a guy yeah maybe you're a great
guy but you're just a guy but you're
still not gonna go that extra little
edge you're not gonna do it because
you're not gonna get credit and you're
not gonna do cuz you don't care that
much about making me look good as you
would if I was taking care of you yeah
there's nothing better than having guys
that you're taking care of they know
you're taking care of them and they're
gonna do anything for you like they're
gonna do anything yeah you you you know
and you'll do anything for them it's a
mutual thing it's real yeah it's a real
thing yeah it's like the gift that keeps
on giving it is you know that's what the
books been so popular and it's and it's
it's why the book has been so popular
because when you when you break it down
and people see what
does they realize how powerful it is yes
and it's and it's also you know another
reason that the book is so popular is
because we put it in a very clear way
and it's easier to understand it doesn't
make it easier to execute but it makes
it easier to understand for sure
yeah it's crazy to and someone said I'm
free and might have been someone at the
muster I don't know could could have
very little bit on Twitter I don't know
but Oh someone's saying how it's so
interesting how they started to realize
that it applies to their relationship
with their like husband or wife or shit
like that and I always kind of look at
all this stuff
is primarily that you know cuz I mean
who do what especially now who do I work
with you I don't go through these
extreme ownership struggles you know
with you so it's more you know so to me
everything up this applies to like your
relationship with your wife my whatever
you know so and it all translates all of
it does yeah when you take ownership of
stuff you it's when you take ownership
of stuff then you can control the
outcome yeah it's crazy when you don't
own it you don't get anywhere yeah and
that that you know you have a
disagreeing argument any any ripples in
the water where the instinct is to point
fingers you know but when you even
though another person is really in the
grand scheme of things you're both to
blame I know that but they do have their
huge role in the issue in the problem
don't do that don't even pay attention
to that all you've got to do is shine
the light on your own things and say
don't I mean and the how you say don't
be don't like be hard on yourself you
know like that kind of like think I suck
I suck it's not that it's no like this
is what I can do exactly right so what's
interesting is and you said it from the
beginning but it is interesting to just
watch it play out so far it's almost fun
but it's more just real interesting
where when you do it and you just keep
doing it you always do it that's thing
consistently do it you just watch how
the other person just changes yeah and
just becomes kind of the same thing and
before you know it like the ripples in
the water are pretty much gone yeah and
what you need someone in the team has
got to start doing it yes that's one of
the hardest things yeah occasionally
well
with a company where everyone's like oh
yeah stream ownership no one is actually
doing it yep when no one is actually
doing it all they're saying is like I
wish that guy had extreme ownership and
that guy should have extreme ownership
and I don't see anyone else taking that
ownership and hey I haven't seen anyone
else taking ownership and therefore how
can I take ownership
you know we send out when we work with a
company we'll send out surveys you know
pre class surveys and in post because
we'll do a number of sessions so we'll
send out to the leadership team that
we're working with how's it going and
we'll send out a week later two weeks
there three weeks later four weeks later
and sometimes when you get a team where
no one is taking ownership in and
literally you'll hear people say well
the boss isn't taking ownership so how
can I take ownership if the boss isn't
even taking ownership they don't realize
that when your boss isn't taking
ownership it is an opportunity for you
to take ownership and to excel and to
gain respect than trust and power and
power which is a good thing because
you're doing things for the good of the
team so you want to have power right I
want to have power when I'm when I'm a
team leader I absolutely want to have
power and the reason I want to have
power so I can distribute it properly
amongst my team mm-hmm and I can utilize
it so we can be successful in our
mission so when you have your CEO isn't
taking ownership awesome I am gonna take
ownership and when my the rest if the
CEO is truly not taking ownership and I
do everyone else looks at me and they
start to elevate my position the CEO
becomes irrelevant because all he's
doing is sitting around pointing fingers
I'm taking ownership of things and
solving them I'm actually gonna end up
in a superior position now I might not
get promoted to CEO today or tomorrow or
in two years but when this information
gets back to the board or to the
directors or whoever they realize that
there's one person that's mutually
respected by everybody and that's you
because you took ownership and when you
take ownership you solve problems and
when you solve problems you win
but somebody has
gotta start it and it's hard sometimes
in some situation do you get the the
what's that word they use like the
caustic environment right toxic the
toxic environment where everyone's just
so so defensive about everything and
it's difficult those are the difficult
situations to to work with you and all
it takes is the transition of one human
one person in that team to step up and
say you know what this stuff that's
going wrong is my fault
CEOs don't worry about him he's got
enough problems he's got to deal with
the he's got a deal
with the shareholders meeting we don't
we need to protect him yeah you know
what this is my fault that this happens
and here's what we're gonna do to fix it
here's what I'm gonna do and that just
changes the attitude ins and of course
you're gonna have two or three people in
that defensive toxic environment that I
don't look at him go yeah that's right
it is your fault you know what you say
to that
yeah yes you're right it is it is my
fault and here's what I'm gonna do fix
it here's how I'm gonna move forward
here's what we're gonna do to change but
it's hard to be that person take that
first step and then you got to keep that
going you know but again man after a
little bit you see the guy next it's in
extreme ownership the book it it's
pointed out but it's not super crystal
clear that when I was taking blame for
the blue on blue that happened everyone
else was too you know those guys were
saying hey it was my fault I did this
was my fault I did this yeah and I was
cuz that was that wasn't the first time
these guys had seen or heard ownership
you know when we were going through
training and something was screwed up
I'd be like hey this is my fault this
one and so everyone had that really good
attitude yeah yeah so and that happens
in a company so what you're saying it
does that's one of the best things about
this idea this principle of extreme
ownership is it spreads throughout the
company and will you get people on the
team that will not take ownership of
things yes of course you will you will
get that person and eventually they will
either leave or you will fire them one
on one of the two things will happen
because when you have a personal you got
the whole team is going nuts my fault
and eventually everyone's oh you oh you
that's not your responsibility core I'll
take that Oh echo you can't handle that
cool that's not
your fault okay then office I'll take it
and fix it oh heck oh you can't handle
that either it's not your fault okay
I'll take that and fix it eventually
don't have a job anymore yeah so if you
want don't want to take ownership of
things including problems I will take
ownership of all of them and I'll
eventually take your job in your world
and it'll be mine it's phase right now
phase you right out like you weren't
even there that's what's gonna happen
so yes it's a powerful powerful tool
yeah and the other thing is you see like
you see politicians do it all the time
they don't take ownership when they make
a mistake and when they do it's sort of
this lip service of hey it was my fault
it was my fault that this happened but
great he bought bla bla bla bla bla anti
and all anyone hears is ba bla bla bla
bla bla bla once as soon as you say but
and then you make a bunch of excuses
that's all anybody hears yeah and
there's just it's so weak yeah it's so
weak to do that and it sounds when like
you said when you get used to hearing it
and you get used to hearing people take
ownership of things when somebody
doesn't it sounds like Satan is
screaming out of their mouths and and
just horrible it sounds awful and it's
like a it's like a cacophony of you just
sickness right that's what it is yeah it
stands up for sure you know when we got
the mustard I was talking about how when
you start taking ownership of things
when you start having this attitude when
when you feel yourself about to make a
mistake it's like you feel like you're
gonna throw up in your mouth it's like
you it's like you it's like vomit is
coming out of your mouth you stroke it
back down because you don't want to let
that puke out onto the floor now that
everyone see it it's not allowed that's
all it is when you blame everyone else
it's all it is it happens all the time
and it's so it's it's the due dates it's
like the other thing I talked about with
with stepping back and and how you step
back off the line and how much
visibility you have as soon as you step
back off the firing line as soon as you
just elevate yourself six inches above
what's happening it's the same thing
when you start to take ownership it's
like the change it's just this little
change but it just completely changes
the dynamic of what is going on in your
business and in your life in your life
because it's the same thing in life when
people are blaming everyone else they're
blaming the market and they're blaming
their parents and they're blaming the
the debt that they built up and they're
blaming the car that broke they're
blaming everything else that's going on
and when you own all you and everything
when nothing is your fault what are you
gonna fix the answer is you're not gonna
fix anything whereas if you go okay
these are some mistakes that I made and
here's what I'm gonna do to fix them
that's the paradigm change and that's
where you start getting on the right
path the muster your lying at the muster
I included it in the video favorite lion
I think says sure I'll take the blame
and I don't care I have a mission took
to accomplish and I got to get the
problem solved yeah
that's what it was yeah in the video
that's part of my opinion yeah I will
take the blame and I don't care I don't
care
bring it